مقاتله روسيتان القتال وقود على مسيره
امريكيه كانت تقوم بمهمه عاديه في المجال
الجوي الدولي وحدث اصطدام مع مقاتله روسيه
هذا يعد حلقه متجدده من افعال الطيارين
الروس المتهوره في المجال الجوي الدولي
اجريت اتصالا هاتفيا مع نظير الروسي وكررت
انه من المهم ان تكون القوه العظمى مثالا
للشفافيه والتواصل الولايات المتحده
ستواصل التحليق في اطار القانون الدولي
ومن مهام روسيا ان تشغل مقاتلاتها بطريقه
احترافيه وامنه في المجال الجوي الدولي
في المقابل اكد مديره الاستخبارات
الخارجيه الروسيه
ان الولايات المتحده تقوم بعمليات استطلاع
نشطه في منطقه البحر الاسود باستخدام
وسائل تكنولوجيه مختلفه قال ناركتان ان
الامريكيين يستخدمون بنشاط كبير جميع
الوسائل خصوصا الاستطلاع البصري
والاستطلاع اللاسلكي وقال سكرتيرو مجلس
الامن الروسي ان موسكو تحاول ايضا العثور
على حطام المسيره الامريكيه التي سقطت امس
في البحر الاسود
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه اعلن بدا تحقيق
في حادث الموجهه بين مسيره الامريكيه
ومقاتله الروسيه فوق البحر الاسود وقال
بلان المواجهه امر متهور وغير امن قبل ذلك
قال متحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الحادثه من المحتمل ان تكون عملا غير
مقصود وقع بسبب عدم كفاءه الطيارين الروس
في المقابل قال وزير الخارجيه
ان الولايات المتحده كانت تتجاهل حقيقه ان
روسيا قد انشات مجانا جويا فوق البحر
الاسود واضاف ان روسيا اسست حدود الرحلات
الجويه في المنطقه بعد بدء الحمله
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا وهي الحقيقه
التي تدركها الولايات المتحده جيدا
احتكاك روسي امريكي خطير مقاتله روسيه
مقابل مسيره امريكيه في تفاصيل الحادثه
التي وصفت بالخطيره
اصطدمت مقاتله روسيه من طراز سوخويت وانت
7 بطائره امريكيه مسيره من طراز ام كيو 9
ريبر وقالت واشنطن ان قواتها اضطرت الى
اسقاط مسيره في البحر الاسود اما موسكو
فتقول ان الحادثه وقعت بالقرب من جزيره
القرم لكن لماذا وجدت مسيره امريكيه
بطريقه استفزت روسيا فوق البحر الاسود
المسؤولون العسكريون الامريكيون يقولون ان
الطائره المسيره كانت تقوم بعمليات
روتينيه في المجال الجوي الدولي اما
البنتاغون فاستنكر الحادثه واتهم
المقاتلات الروسيه بالقاء الوقود امام
المسيرات الامريكيه الا انه رفض الافصاح
عما اذا كانت مسيره مسلحه ام لا
المهمه التي كانت تقوم بها بينما للروس
روايه اخرى فهم ينظرون للحادث باعتباره
استفزازا موسكو نفتعمدها اسقاط المسيره
الامريكيه وقالت ان
تحطمت بعد ارتطامها بسطح البحر الاسود
لاسباب تعود لفقدانها الارتفاع بعد قيامها
بمناوره حاده واثناء تحليقها اطفات اجهزه
تعريفها في انتهاك لمنطقه الحظر الجوي ما
دفع مقاتلتين روسيتين الاعتراضها الا
انهما لم تسقطاها ولم تقتربا منها بشكل
خطير مستبعدين رغبه موسكو بالمواجهه مع
واشنطن حتى الان للولايات المتحده ولا
روسيا تمكنتا من استعاده حطام المسيره
الامريكيه الا ان هذا التصعيد الاخير حذر
منه مسؤول البلدين خاصه وانه اول مواجهه
مباشره بين الطرفين منذ بدء الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا روان حمزه العربيه
اتابع تفاصيل من واشنطن مع زميل بايران
الى اي مدى تخشى الولايات المتحده من سقوط
هذه الطائره في قبضه القوات الروسيه مع
انها تتحدث اكثر من مره بانها قد قامت
بازاله ومسح جميع البيانات لدى هذه
الطائره
ليس كثيرا اولا لان الامريكيين دمروا
البرامج الموجوده على هذه الطائره وهذه
المسيره سقطت في المياه الدوليه على عمق
الف متر وسوف يكون من الصعب على الروس ان
يصلوا الى حطام هذه الطائره وربما يصل
اليها حلفاء للامريكيين وهذا ما يعمل عليه
الامريكيون الان قبل ان يصل اليها الروس
بالاضافه الى هذا وذاك لا يعتبر
الامريكيون وقد تحدث الجنرال قبل قليل الى
جانب وزيره الدفاع الامريكيه حول هذا
الموضوع وهم لا يعلقون اهميه على مساله
الحطام طيب اذا كانوا لا يعلقون مساله على
هذا الحطام لماذا كل هذا البحث المطر سواء
من قبل الروس او حتى الولايات المتحده وهل
هناك اساليب معينه تستخدمها واشنطن في هذه
المرحله للوصول الى طائراتها وان كانت
البيانات قد مسحته لك على الاقل تحمل
تقنيه امريكيه متقدمه
قبل قليل ان ليست هناك قوات بحريه امريكيه
موجوده في منطقه البحر الاسود ولكن قال
وزير الدفاع على امريكي والجرى قبل قليل
ان هناك قوات حليفه موجوده في المنطقه
وتستطيع ان نتحدث هنا عنها بشكل خاص عن
رومانيا وبلغاريا وتستطيع ان نتحدث ايضا
عن تركيا وهي جميعها قادره على القيام
بعمليات البحث والوصول الى حطام هذه
الطائره كان هناك تخوف بالامس من ان تتطور
هذه الحادثه الى ازمه جديده في العلاقات
الامريكيه الروسيه ما بعد اوكرانيا من
خلال التصريحات التي صدرت هل هناك اجواء
تهدئه ام تصعيد في واشنطن
كان الكلام على الامريكي اليوم حازما
ولكنه كان من الواضح انها الامريكيين
يريدون ابقاء خطوط الاتصال مفتوحه مع
الروس
وزير الدفاع على الامريكيه هو الذي بادر
للاتصال بزميله الروسي وتحدث اليه اليوم
الجيره الملي الرئيس هيئه اركان المشتركه
هو ايضا سوف يتحدث الى نظيره الروسي
الامريكيون من الواضح انهم يريدون ابقاء
خطوط الاتصال مفتوحه بالاضافه الى ذلك
يريدون ويتعمدون القول ان هذه المساله
ليست مساله عسكريه وليست مساله مواجهه ولا
تصعيد المساله هي مساله قانونيه في
معلومات خاصه بنا نستطيع القول ان هذه
المسيره كانت تطير على مسافه 75 ميل بحري
من جزيره القرب اي انها كانت في الاجواء
الدوليه وفوق مياه دوليه وبالتالي
الامريكيون يتمسكون بالمبدا الذي يقول انه
من حق الامريكيه ان
تطير هذه الطائره في الاجواء الدوليه وهذا
ينطبق ايضا على الروس ولكنه لا تستطيع
روسيا بالمقابل برايي الامريكيين فرض
اجواء من عندها فقط لانها تقول ان هذه هي
الاجواء التابعه لنا وبالتالي ويريد
الامريكيون التاكيد على هذا وهذا ما اورده
ايضا في حديثه مع نظيره الروسي
تبحث الولايات المتحده بالقرب من جزيره
شبه جزيره القرم وهل ستستمر تلك العمليات
بحسب بيانات
بدون شك ان الامريكيين يريدون متابعه هذه
العمليات بقرب جزيره القرب لا يقولون بشكل
مباشر ان هذه الطائره كانت تقوم بعمليات
مسح للقوات الروسيه الموجوده على جزيره
القرم وبالتالي هم يحاولون التجسس لمصلحه
اوكرانيا ولكن اي ناظر لهذه المساله يفهم
انها الامريكيين يستعملون المجال الدولي
للتجسس على الروس ويحاولون المساعده
الاوكرانيين واليوم جدد وزير الدفاع على
امريكي كلام واضح من خلال مجموعه العمل
ومساعده اوكرانيا الى ان الامريكيين مع
خمسين دوله اخرى يقفون الى جانب اوكرانيا
ويعتبرون ان روسيا هي دوله معتديه ويجب ان
توقف هذا
الاعتداء على دوله اوكرانيا
من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك